my daughter Rachel Cruz joins me for a
couple of segments as she does every
week now talk kids and money talk
something through we're talking through
different subjects that we covered in
our book which comes out of April April
22nd called smart money smart kids you
can pre-order the book now at amazon.com
barnesandnoble.com Dave Ramsey comm if
you preorder it we are going to throw in
50 dollars worth of stuff we're going to
sell it to you at Dave Ramsey comm for
20 bucks it's a 25 dollar book we're
giving you a bunch of extra stuff
because it helps us if you preorder
because it helps drive you know all
those sales count towards the some of
the bestseller lists and we're not
trying to manipulate the list the list
is actually works that way we're just
trying to say hey we want to sell a
whole bunch of books and so that we are
a legitimate best seller it's that
simple
so Rachel's with me we're talking today
from smart money smart kids you can get
the book by the way of Dave Ramsey calm
the $50 where the extras is the e-book
the audiobook and the securing your
legacy safeguarding your legacy video
that will give you as well it's $50
where the items and the books five
dollars off at dave ramsey calm if you
buy it at one of the other places you
just got to go to smart money smart kids
calm and fill out the paperwork with
your proof of purchase and also we can
send you your free free stuff that is if
you pre purchased the book before April
22nd April 22nd is going to be here
really fast it's coming up quick only
about two months away so we're talking
about weddings and we talked about
setting up a budget with a fixed amount
upfront and that the average household
income is 52,000 in America and the
average wedding is 28,000 there's
certainly a lot of weddings that cost a
lot less than that
that are absolutely awesome and that
people do a great job with and you know
one thing we didn't mention rachel is
and sometimes you and i just assumed
this is you're paying cash you don't go
in debt for your stupid wedding under
any circumstances that is just ludicrous
you know just crazy to do stuff like
that and yet people do it all the time
and you know I actually got a I can find
it here an email oh yes this is awesome
takes out $10,000 debt for their wedding
my wife and I work for a church in New
York and when the economy started to
have trouble the church stopped paying
us or we would power the past a month
late we took out a $10,000 loan for our
wedding and paid off half of it but then
we weren't able to make the payments we
contacted the lender now they're suing
us we're thinking about filing
bankruptcy on a wedding loan not a good
memory on a wedding waiting yeah you're
gonna repossess the dress I mean oh my
gosh yeah so yuck yeah paying cash
obviously but all the way down to going
to the preacher with 50 bucks and saying
marry me yes oh don't don't just
whatever the budget is the budget has to
be in cash that's right don't let your
wedding follow you past the honeymoon
phase just just it nip it in the bud
right there pay cash for it yes
can you imagine telling your grandkids
later that the wedding bankrupted you I
mean that's just
I just blows my mind it's just awful wow
wow wow wow that's something else well
the deal is to moms and dads one thing
to remember in this from a control
standpoint is you can control the
boundaries you put around the wedding
but it is not your wedding and some moms
more than dads some dads too but some
moms really get so involved in the
wedding it's almost like they're getting
married again
or they're having the wedding through
their daughter they never had or
whatever the deal is and you really got
to give your you know you got to give
your child some boundaries and and then
you can give them great ideas creative
ideas but you become a participant then
you're not managing the whole process
the only thing you're managing if you're
putting up the money is the amount right
yeah that's right and I think you know
you're giving your your daughter if it's
the case of the wedding you know a gift
to budget a sum of money herself and her
and her fiance do that and if you're you
know heavy-handed over every decision
that can probably not result and a lot
of good things financially or
emotionally probably for your daughter
so be the cheerleader for sure but as
the daughter if you're listening and you
are the daughter that has received some
money to pay for your wedding obviously
be grateful and see that as a tremendous
gift a lot of people do not get that
opportunity
and so see that and be and be thankful
for that yeah and you and Winston
working together that was almost like
your first budgeting opportunity
together wasn't it yes learned some
things about each other
you're going through pre-marriage
counseling while you're doing all of
this and you've got this wedding budget
pressure so you it became almost a
marriage teaching tool for you all
didn't it yeah I'm glad he stayed with
me consider you broke the budget married
a spender no but it was it had good
discussion you know we had great
discussions around it and yeah you kind
of see your personality come out within
it and so obviously I advise people not
to combine your money until you've said
I do but the wedding budget I think can
be an exception especially if you
obviously are secure in the relationship
and know you're going to go forward with
it for that just to be a great learning
opportunity and again you you discover
things about yourself and your fiance
that you may or may not have discovered
all right let's go to Erin in Cincinnati
who has a question or comment about
weddings and wedding budgets Erin your
question for Rachel and I idea thanks
for taking my call how are you good
thank you Erin my question really
regards to it's exactly what you guys
are talking about my wife and I we just
finished baby step three so we're moving
on to saving for kids college and we're
looking at planning all that kind of
stuff but I particularly have also been
thinking about weddings way down the
road we've got two little girls ages
five and two so we've got plenty of time
but I was kind of just thinking what's
the best vehicle for that you know
they're just mutual funds or you know
which I don't want to just put it in a
money market or something that's not
going to really grow I want it to be
protected and then also I guess they're
just kind of relates to that priorities
you know with when it comes to our 401 K
and then obviously we're trying to save
for college as well you know we're what
should the already step be there well we
use of course baby step four or 15% of
your income going into retirement that's
a priority college is baby Step five and
that's a priority you know if I had to
choose between a child graduating from
college debt-free and child having a big
fancy wedding I'm going to choose
college in about a nanosecond and that's
that's the
value system of the Ramseys because we
believe knowledge gives you the ability
to propel into the future we did not set
aside at our house separate funds for a
wedding fund it's not necessarily a bad
idea but we didn't do it we just had
money invested and we took some of that
invested money and just pulled a little
bit out and as I said with Rachel and
Winston just wrote them a check and
opened them up a wedding account so it
really wasn't earmarked but it was more
just in general beyond our retirement
beyond our you know the baby steps that
the college and then paying off the
house beyond that we just generally
built some wealth and investments and we
used some of those investments to do
that and it was of course nowhere near
half of our annual income we wouldn't
have even thought of that that would
have been absurd
I wish yeah not really you don't either
it would have been on the news but now
you just don't so you got you just got
to keep it in balance that way and start
thinking towards that but you know if
you're in a tight budgeting situation
and you're not making huge eda on paying
off the house and those kinds of things
it's probably going to mean a modest
wedding and that's fine buddy because
we're choosing college and paying off
the home and having a retirement ahead
of the size of the wedding and that
would be my priority by far because I
know that sounds a little a little
financial planner or whatever maybe not
a little so romantic but again a wedding
is a wonderful thing but it is one
freaking day but Erin I commend you to
say that your girls are already you know
so young and you're already thinking
about this and you guys are already on
baby step three so more than likely by
the time yeah they turn 25 or help
however they all old they are when they
get married
I'm sure you guys will be perfectly fine
to help with that you're all running the
track dude you're gonna be fine you're
not gonna have a problem you're at
Rachel's right you're and the cool thing
is that this that when you start
thinking about something like that when
they're that age you're so far ahead of
most parents who are just trying to pay
the light bill by Friday and they're not
thinking about the kid at all except
maybe feeding them you know but
certainly not thinking about their
college not thinking about a future
wedding or those kinds of things but
yeah it can be pricey and so you've got
to think about it because I know
I have known peers of ours and Rachel's
you know contemporaries who their
parents would go take out a home equity
loan or something like that to do the
wedding and again we're saying cash set
out a budget ahead of time look at some
ratios all of that budgeting process for
the wedding and handling the whole
concept of the wedding is in the smart
money smart kids book and stay on top of
it
Rach thanks for joining me again yeah
thanks for having me all right smart
kids smart money book is on sale as I
said at Dave Ramsey comm it's on sale of
course at amazon.com barnesandnoble.com
and be sure you pick up yours before the
before the street date so you get those
bonus items this is the Dave Ramsey show
you